hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
christmas kraft wir befinden uns heute
in der sechsten folge sechste ich glaube
wir sind in der sechsten und der bau
vorschlag kommt heute von bubble girl
die uns war es eine sternschnuppe
unterthemen vorschlag ist von spex gfx
und zwar fragt er mich hey leute was
machst du eigentlich so zu silvester
also wo ich mich darum bewegen was ich
darüber ob mache ich mich überhaupt
bewegung ob ich aber nur um liebe ob ich
da schon längst robin weil die welt
untergegangen ist meistens nicht
jedenfalls möchte er das gerne von mir
wissen und und wir dürfen ihr
weihnachtsmann nicht niedlich und ich
finde den echt ein bisschen bescheuert
also pech man dieses gesicht an das
total psycho also eine sternschnuppe
mehr fragt sie natürlich erst mal wobei
die hin
da dachte ich mir dass passten muss auf
jeden fall in die nähe von diesem dings
deswegen werde ich dich hier irgendwo
hin bauen
also ich meine die muss ja ganz einfach
in der luft oder frage ich mich auch
gerade woraus kann ich eigentlich bauen
ich denke ich werde die nicht aus holz
sondern bloß dann passt doch sponge das
eigentlich schon ganz gut glaube ich
eurer gelb nicht ob geld ist sogar noch
besser
das heißt ich werde hier einfach mal so
hoch bauen das wäre sehr sehr kurzer
folge heute echt leid aber ich muss
sagen wir diese folge säten ich übrigens
gerade in weimar auf stufen fahrt und
zwar machen wir eine kulturelle reise
was wahrscheinlich eh nur darin enden
wir dass wir dann alle total viel saufen
und so weiter aber es ist kalt oder
erstes wird beschrieben als eine
kulturelle stufen fahrt naja jedenfalls
ganz cool
da bin ich gerade deswegen lade ich hier
die folgen schon mal hoch so wir bauen
eine sternschnuppe
die baumart denn na ja ich wollte auf
jeden fall darüber reden was mache ich
so zu weihnachten zu silvester nicht zu
weihnachten ja
es können halt sagen was mache ich denn
da überhaupt sein kumpel also ich bin
dass da steht eigentlich gar nichts
weise besser ist noch relativ weit weg
aber ich bin schon auf zwei partys sage
ich mal eingeladen
ich weiß halt noch nicht welchen die
also auf jeden fall nicht zu hause mit
familie oder so dass er mich ja welche
gefragt nicht weil ich meine familie
nicht mag sondern ganz einfach weil es
auch an mein gott das sollen stern sein
ich kann so was von nicht bauen einfach
weil ich da was mit freund machen will
und so also ist eigentlich auch
verständlich kann das ding mal mein gott
das ist doch nie im leben stern denn wie
will man auch ein sterne minecraft bauen
hallo da frage ich mich war dass ich
mich immer wieder denkt euch einfach das
ist ein stern basta
sag ich mal in steifen schweiz und werde
dann wahrscheinlich weniger party seine
seinem 48 mal party das wird denke ich
ganz schöner schock könnten den
eventuellen erst auf das wird glaube ich
ganz cool werden da und jo also das
werde ich machen denke ich also fertig
zu bauen wollte zwei sofas und so
irgendwie so ein bisschen so ein
bisschen abgeknickt
so
also ganz einfach ich sag mal feiern
ganz gruppiert so kann man das erkennen
man kann es eventuell erkennen also das
soll ein schwein sein
na ja ich würde sagen ich noch einen
zweiten und zwar hier ist noch keiner
ich baue ihnen einfach mal drüber über
diesen typen hier ganz hoch hier
irgendwie auf die höhe oder so
da müssen ja dann eine silvester was
machen wir dann also ich denke erst mal
wie wir trinken bisschen milch also auch
in weimar wenn es weimar bin trink mir
natürlich auch nur mich weil mich schon
hartes geschäft
und dann werden wir natürlich warten bis
12 uhr ist die uhr zwölf schlägt und
danach wird von etwas danach halt
silvesterraketen aber ich denke ich bin
nicht so der typ der die ganze zeit
draußen steht also voll begeistert von
dem ganzen 100 wetter und die ganze
raketen die anderen luft geschossen
werden
ich finde das einfach eiskalt draußen
ich wieder viele bei sie drinnen sitzen
bleiben wird als eher gemütlich angucken
zeichner sei schon mal so ganz offen was
mache ich das da noch sagen mach das
einfach hier frei laune
ich bin ja mehr der typ der einfach drin
hockt und minecraft zockt borders
endlich geräumt
nein ich nehme auf
was willst du ich nehme aus ja ich hab's
einfach den link war da schon das zweite
mal dass einer statistin school habe ich
nicht gewinnen
keine ordnung zehn minuten
so soll
wer folgt
voll cool wenn du das irgendwie ein
anders machen können vielleicht auch mit
tschüss
so das war meine mutter wird gestört
irgendwie komischerweise den letzten
folgen mein vater gestellt immer ganz
witzig naja was das jetzt wird es diesen
abgehackt ausbauen
doch das sollte sich auf jeden fall
komisch aus also dass sollen
sternschnuppen seien ja ganz erkennen
kann ist eine andere sache ich lass uns
jetzt einfach drin mit meiner mutter das
sind gut weil ihr wollt ja immer auf ex
und wisst ihr was wir jetzt dabei sein
kann ich dem weihnachtsmann ja meinen
sohn bommel mit zehn abbauen
das haben mir alle gesagt obama eine
bombe mit dem ding war da war meine
bommel mit ca okay okay wenn ihr das
sagte mach ich das erstens kraft ist
eine idee ganz auf euch bezogen sage ich
mal
oh mann das sollte aber auch nicht so
komisch aus dem sack ich meine wette ich
brauche das ich wahrscheinlich dass
bauer
wollt ihr denn bommel drauf wo mein gott
ja ok man kann erkennen dass es ungefähr
eine bommel mit darstellen so komisch
aus
ohne witz ich kann einfach sowas von
nicht bauen aber man kann glaube ich
wenn man sich das gesamtpaket so ankommt
erkennt man dass es eine weihnachtswelt
sein soll
aber gut das war s dann würde ich sagen
erst mal für diese folge also silvester
eigentlich party regiert der luft
schießt dort heute mit bild.de
übrigens an bubble girl i für den bau
vorschlag man relativ kurzer folge sogar
mit autorin noch relativ kurz obwohl
eigentlich habe ich von anfang an mir
gedacht dass ein christmas stoff folge
fünf minuten lang wird wenn ich jetzt
etwas klein und sachen creative note
ja und auch danke ans plexiglas für den
themen vorschlagen ihr könnt mir
weiterhin themenvorschläge und bau
vorschläge in die kommentare schreiben
werde ich auf jeden fall sehr dankbar
sehr dankbar über die sonne geht hier
gerade unter und dann würde ich ganz
einfach sagen sie mit seiner nächsten
folge ich suche weiterhin geschichten
und sowas so für wenn ihr am zehnten
spieler gewinnen könnt also könnte es
auch einen kommentar schreiben
und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
also ja ach so was ich noch sagen wollte
da ich ja jetzt die zeit erst mal weg
bin hoffe ich einfach dass die die
videos kommen werden dass wenn es ja
gerade wenig erweckt ich hoffe einfach
dass die videos kommen werden so wie ich
das eingestellt habe
und wenn nicht dann bitte einfach nicht
rumheulen und dazu sondern einfach ein
bisschen abwarten die videos werden
schon kommen dass ich bin
samstagnachmittag wieder da und dann
kann ich euch gleich wieder sonntag die
folge bringen während gewonnen hat bei
christmas kraft bei dem ersten match
wird ja dann will ich sagen schaffen wir
eventuell 406 für diesen geilen
sternschnuppen pro sieht ganz schön
düster 30 bilder ein bisschen gemütlich
also ich habe mir 400 für diese richtig
geilen sternschnuppen ich sag mal
richtig geil in anführungszeichen diesen
wirklich scheiße aus aber ich verstehe
ja viel zu viel wir sind wieder bei neun
minuten okay ich hab schon wieder zwei
minuten die zentralisten leute